someone picks up our your shot we hope
that it inspires them to just we have
their camera like they they just want to
make something
we want to see those things that you
want to keep your life forever and hope
that you share those with us these
moments are around us all time and
what's so wonderful about your shot is
we've got these regional photographers
out there capturing we love is your shy
photographs for variety of reasons
they're completely fresh and they are
unassigned and taken for the pure
selfish boy of the photographer when I'm
looking at your shot pictures I'm
welcome to play I'm looking for pictures
that make me smile that sense of
curiosity and playfulness there's a
transference that happens when the
doctor takes a picture of a genuine mind
of playfulness that authenticity and
that playfulness is communicated somehow
and we we can see it
there isn't something characteristic
that you can say makes a photograph job
as I'm going to the pictures I'm
thinking do I just not want to go past
it like because I want more the second
time around you think harder you are
really like that they're really stopping
again and then the third time it's just
like which of the best ones which really
do I want to look at more and more and
more and so that after looking at a
picture that many times and it still
pleases you that's like gay ok guess
it's good people who sent these images
in didn't know what would happen to the
images and Oliver and I liked them so
much that we want to then pass them on
which Goods progress are like that
you